[Music]
No Oh night Oh lalalalalala the Martin
Amana all-merciful tell something about
New Zealand
80,000 bases across the video space
[Music]
okay before we go any further
this is absolutely it's the small brown
and black bird whose nest are a highly
sought-after delicacy here in the
Philippines that people eat them in a
soup called well bird's nest soup
typically these nests are found a high
high up on cliffs super hard to get you
and we've been taco Muslims in thousand
onta at the very deep think it out son
so Bernie's burglars n Eddie didn't kick
them out instead he gave him half his
home similar salami Tamara beat or 1993
don't see us first
Lorna behind operation Sanford Priscilla
nest Lila Abu vanilla
saliva CMT gusano epoxy a beer a Badman
and 10 minutes 20 minutes to be laggy
parents ago so they boil it add some
veggies a bit of meat and voila bird's
nest soup little anchovy pneumococci a
picto a shark in an epic tour lolly
passion that one more problem Alamitos
armenia pop insane or nila yung a manila
prepared our mental or big snack for my
personal only buying the kaya
understandably so some people they just
can't appreciate the smell of 80,000
birds worth of droppings but Eddie in
the swiftlets have an arrangement
Alicia nominee bonus up friend Alana
legacy and eternal children a catalyst
of bhai byron borders inaba eirin de la
Frontera militant
[Music]
siempre is a Denali knock a la nación e
tieba can come up florida p el ateneo
doc aida body attacking it's a party
then three egg okay we know assuming
intro employer concern etc I mean hombre
is Alexander Blanco Marquis toe Americo
veterinary Oh me Pacey Rizzo Messina
conservación de la guerre RPN Venezuela
una pesca se queda a - ah de dentro la
lista Roja de la una Mundi op a lock on
soullow son Donato da Lisa debido a la
pérdida de la vita e volakis area in
discriminate
para me es la palma maje to OSA del
bosque su Gaara Sunday Kings Ascenta
Metro marrón de que de unos o Pardo
sue Emery Ghidorah suta mono la fuerza
la intelligentsia madonna keratolytic
afford me reveille para circus elo
animal and mask impresionante
[Applause]
[Music]
básicamente s Kalama to Haru allocate an
un promedio entre los querida currentc
in Co Metro
[Music]
actor amo help each own el nido ello
bahama para evitar a pump--ow salata que
ellos padre en primer lugar loca loca
Mogan identificación para nosotros Acala
en el espacio un lugar determine oddo
en el futuro a devotee su algo - tada
Dora yo Treme Dida importante para de to
do Delanie mal un trabajo peligrosos da
mo hablando cheat amo entrando dentro al
dominio date isla de un buen estado de
salud M barrio oportunidad a sufrió
akkada de arbol a Mika yet rentee Ocho
Metro a al Turin ki doli or a que de
literalmente in Tehran el piso no safe
way no - tan locos Mazda vehicle Ando
Paraguay no es mi trabajo y SME
compromiso conmigo mio en primer lugar y
SI no se hace muy loco no Seco no Sierra
mucho de la oeil y ND ah no mo da cuenta
que la ascensión not--it robado
principalmente a crea conciencia a las
personas de la comunidad a donde cohabit
an con el agua
[Applause]
sirrah persona aprenden econo ser
protein approach ahead second Sarah des
otro mo trabajo con las una pero ahora
Tommo viendo resultado de nuestro
proyecto totin a un total de siento
Cinco nido aproximadamente yes okay
sequence data formal odda or so tau
alt-rock a second a koala relay
opposite koala difficult are a nosotros
agimo LRT
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm a particle of the low dearmond on
the way another what you wanna tell ya a
little get-together in Chennai India
there's a tiny camera repair shop run by
a man named Joseph say car and I had the
Sager and brother priority but although
he's not the Birdman Andre say car got
his nickname because every day he feeds
thousands of hungry parakeets on the
roof of his home he wandering the other
motor eating idiot I'm gonna Mario what
we reaffirm our cattle our nom nom nom
about Who am I
[Music]
the 2006 tsunami that hit Southeast Asia
flooded parts of India and displaced
thousands of birds sake are noticed a
pair of parakeets outside of his home
and set some rice out for them then more
started to show up and well doing the
personal indestructible day everybody
and the worried 8000 connected so that
feeding 8,000 parakeets twice a day is a
great expense sake our spends about 40%
of the money he makes from repairing
cameras buying food for the birds
you know Deva let's see what download is
a part but for the Birdman of Chennai
there's more to life than money
fernanda I'll kill em upon I want to
tear it up anime Valkyrie left one thing
over money then you get there I cannot
tear Wikimedia still appear upon a
thermal again bill are supported on over
there you know what we're not gonna give
me the money you cannot over they be
seen under motives on my car normally I
know Ricardo Miata
move in jello we don't like it no we
don't there are so many egos here bald
eagles are our national burden for most
people in the u.s. there are rare and
magnificent sighting but for us it's
just part of our daily lives everybody
in town has an eagle Suri
[Music]
I'm Carlin and Lowe born and raised in
Alaska and I am the Unalaska Visitors
Bureau executive director even though
our island is almost 80 miles long there
are nearly 600 birds and just a few
square miles which is crazy there's an
unnatural amount of birds here because
we contribute to their food source these
bald eagles are so amazing and we love
seeing them but when they're involved in
your daily life they can make running
errands or your work really difficult
you need something as simple as mailing
a letter can be dangerous I'm officer
would with the an Alaska Department of
Public Safety our department put up
these signs too one of the community
about the dangers of the nesting Eagles
which are right next to the post office
Eagles have been known to swoop down and
attack people they're very territorial
and they're just trying to protect their
nests the eagle's nest is right there
and here is the post office some people
have been hurt during these incidents
but I've also heard some funny stories
I'm Pam Oz and I run bingo here at the
Senior Center every other Sunday I was
carrying this box it had something like
bingo stuff in it all of a sudden a wing
hit my head the talons came down grabbed
the box and flew down the street and I
never saw my being a box again but if
you want to see a whole lot of eagles
you go to the landfill I'm Steve bastok
I work at the city of Onalaska landfill
one of my favorite places to be also one
of the Eagles favorite places to be I
know that Eagles are scavengers and
predators so they like trash to they'll
pick up whatever they think might be
food my name is Bob Wilson I've been
fishing out of the Bering Sea and Dutch
Harbor for 40 years Dutch Harbor is one
of the largest fishing ports in the
world every time we pull in we know the
Eagles are waiting for us so they can
steal our fish as we offload it do I
think they're pests oh absolutely but
they're cool pests so that's okay
they make a mess of my boat which is
kind of the bad part but they are
national bird and we love them anyway
how's that
[Music]